Freitag 27 Oktober 2023 Israel startet
die zweite Phase seiner Operation gegen
die Hamas im Gazastreifen die
Bodenoffensive die IDF führen einen
großangelegten Bodenangriff auf die
Städte beanon und B im Gazastreifen
durch Luftangriffe werden in Gaza
Mobilfunk und Internet ausgeschaltet
Samstag 28 Oktober 2023 Benjamin natahu
verkündet nun auch offiziell den Start
der zweiten Phase der Operation im
Gazastreifen Montag 29 Oktober 2023 die
israelischen Streitkräfte Rücken auf
drei Achsen im Gazastreifen vor od
erobern die Stadt asiafa Montag 30
Oktober 2023 die IDF Rücken mit
Panzerverbänden in Gaza ein sie
schneiden die Salah aldinstraße eine
wichtige Verbindungsstraße zwischen dem
nördlichen und südlichen Teil des
Gazastreifens ab außerdem wurden
israelische Panzer auch im seitunviertel
von Gaza Stadt gesichtet mit
Unterstützung von shinvet und mossat
befreien sie ein entführte Soldatin aus
der Gefangenschaft der Hamas es gelingt
Ihnen den Kommandeur des beitlahia
Bataillons der hamasbrigade Nord nasim
Abu ajina zu töten dieser leitete am 7
Oktober das Massaker an israelischen
Zivilisten im kibut RS und in netivha
Asara befehligte die Hamas Luftabwehr
und war an der Entwicklung der drohen
und Gleitschirme der Terrororganisation
beteiligt Dienstag 31 Oktober 2023
mittlerweile sind die israelischen
Verbände im Gazastreifen in heftige
Gefechte verwickelt um Verteidigungs und
panzerabwehrstellungen der Hamas
auszuschalten nach Angaben der IDF haben
die Truppen bei den Kämpfen städtischen
Gebieten Dutzende von Terroristen
getötet und zahlreiche Waffen erbeutet
der Leiter des IDF südkommandos
brigadener jaron finkelmann schwört mit
einer Rede seine Soldaten auf einen
langen und schweren Kampf gegen die
kamamas in Gaza ein die aber nur ein
Ergebnis haben könne den Sieg Israels
drei Wochen lang bombardierten die
israelischen Verteidigungskräfte IDF als
Vorbereitung ihrer bodenoperation die
Stellungen Waffenlager und
Kommandozentralen der Hamas im
Gazastreifen da sich diese oft
absichtlich in oder unter zivilen
Gebäuden befinden häufig Schulen oder
Krankenhäusern geben die IDF vor jeden
Luftangriff eine Warnung aus damit sich
die Zivilbevölkerung rechtzeitig in
Sicherheit begeben kann ein Maß an
Rücksichtnahme und Humanität das
weltweit seines gleichen sucht vor allem
wenn man bedenkt dass ein großer Teil
der Bevölkerung Gazas mit den Hamas
Terroristen sympathisiert oder sie sogar
aktiv unterstützt trotzdem bekommen Sie
die Chance in den südlichen Teil des
Gasastreifen zu flüchten der zunächst
von den härtesten Angriffen verschont
bleibt aber damit kein Zweifel aufkommt
die Regierung Israels hat beschworen
alle für den Anschlag vom 7 Oktober
Verantwort lichen zu töten und der
chamas ein für alle mal ein Ende zu
setzen um das zu erreichen wird sie
alles einsetzen müssen was sie hat
bisher gingen die Israelis nämlich davon
aus dass sie sich mit dem Terror mit dem
ihre Nachbarn sie überziehen irgendwie
arrangieren können klar sich an ein
Leben in Angst vor dem Terror und der
ständigen Gegenwart von Raketenangriffen
zu gewöhnen den permanenten Bewusstsein
jederzeit in einen luftschussbunker
flüchten zu müssen stellt einen
hohenpreis da aber dieser Preis erschien
den Israelis bis zum 7 Oktober gerade so
akzeptabel um nicht in einen
vollständigen Krieg eintreten zu müssen
mit allen nationalen regionalen und
geopolitischen Konsequenzen doch das
alles hat sich mit dem beispiellosen
Terroranschlag der Hamas geändert Israel
wird nun keine Mittel scheuen die zweite
Phase der Operation eiserne Schwerter
hat ein klares Ziel die Hamas zu
zerschlagen und den Bedrohungen aus dem
Gazastreifen ein für allem mal ein Ende
zu
setzenasas wen
[Musik]
seit dem Angriff der Hamas am 7 oktober
haben sowohl die israelische Luftwaffe
die bodenstreitkräfte sowie Marine
Spezialkräfte und Geheimdienste
intensivst an der Vorbereitung der
bodeninvasion gearbeitet sie haben
versucht die wichtigste Infrastruktur
und alle Einrichtungen zu zerstören die
von der Hamas genutzt werden könnten um
israelische Soldaten anzugreifen wenn
die Zeit gekommen ist es wurden auch
einzelne Kommandooperationen zum Zwecke
der taktischen Aufklärung ausgeführt und
um Wege zur Schonung bzw Befreiung der
von der Hamas gehaltenen israelischen
und internationalen Geiseln zu erkunden
das Ziel sowohl des schweren
Bombardements als auch der Einzelmission
war es die Stadt auf die bodeninvasion
vorzubereiten und die Zahl der Opfer in
den israelischen Reihen zu minimieren
und auch wenn es für manche bereits wie
eine harte Militäraktion aussah es war
nur der auftrakt zu einem echten Inferno
in diesem Video werden wir daher
folgende brennenden Fragen klären welche
genauen Bedrohungen erwarten Israel
welche Bedeutung hat die bodenin
überhaupt wie genau wird sie ablaufen
und inwi weit sind die Israelis und
gasana auf den kommenden Sturm
vorbereitet wir werden diese Fragen
heute aus einem für die meisten
Beobachter vielleicht etwas ungewohnten
Blickwinkel betrachten um eine besonders
hohe analyseschärfe zu erreichen wundert
euch also nicht wenn dies Video etwas
anders wird als das was ihr
üblicherweise in den Nachrichten zu
sehen bekommt lasst uns vorher aber noch
einen wichtigen Werbehinweis unseres
Trollen Sponsors sfsark einspielen damit
wir danach sofort fortfahren können denn
wusstet ihr dass viele Firmen wie z.B
airlin ganz unterschiedliche Preise
anbieten können je nachdem von welchem
Land aus man bestellt bzw ein Ticket
Bucht nun zum Glück kann man solche
preisdiskriminierungsversuche mit Hilfe
eines VPNs überlisten und dann richtig
Geld sparen und surar VPN ist ein
wirklich empfehlenswertes und sicheres
VPN welche z.B keinerlei
Verbindungsdaten mitlockt ein Virtual
Private Network was VPN ist aber nicht
nur zum geldparen geeignet denn es kann
einen auch vor so mancher Gefahr
schützen die im Netz lauert natürlich
muss man nach wie vor Umsicht walten
lassen und wissen was man tut aber er
stellt hierfür ein Werkzeug mit gleich
mehreren Vorteilen da zum einen
erschwert es in Kombination mit anderen
Vorkehrungen eure Aktionen nzen
nachzuverfolgen und abzuhören mit Hilfe
verschiedener Sicherheitsfeatures könnt
ihr so eure Anonymität im Netz erhöhen
z.B mit dem integrierten cleanwb das
alle unerwünschten Cookies und Pop-ups
blockt weiterer Vorteil eines vband ist
dass ihr so tun könnt als wät ihr an
einem anderen Ort so könnt ihr dann z.B
auf Websites und Internetdienste
zugreifen die in dem Land in ihr gerade
seid überhaupt nicht verfügbar wären ob
daheim oder im Urlaub damit schlagt die
Zensur und geoblocking ein Schnippchen
Netflix und andere Streamingdienste die
ihre Inhalte nur in den USA Anbieten von
Europa aus ausnutzen oder deutsches
Internetfernsehen im ausßenland gucken
mit surfchar kein Problem aber das ist
noch lange nicht alles denn mit nur
einem surfchar Konto könnt ihr wirklich
alle eure Endgeräte im vop registrieren
Handys Notebooks oder sogar euren Smart
TV so und wenn ihr den Rabattcode
politik.de angeht bekommt ihr von surfck
auch noch die ersten drei Monate gratis
dazu den Link zu diesem Angebot findet
ihr in der Beschreibung unter diesem
Video also näch Videos besorgt euch sur
und greift damit gleichzeitig auch uns
finanziell unter die Arme das könnt ihr
übrigens auch direkt mit Hilfe des
spendenlinks den ich euch ebenfalls in
die Beschreibung gepackt habe wir sind
euch für jede Unterstützung dankbar denn
damit helft ihr uns euch in Zukunft noch
mehr und noch bessere Videos zu liefern
so und wenn ihr das erledigt habt lasst
uns sofort ins Thema eintauchen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
aufgepasst die Israelis wollen in Gaza
einen regime change vollziehen sie geben
sich nicht länger mit einer Strafaktion
zufrieden und den Feind abzuschrecken um
sich dann anschließend irgendwie mit ihm
zu arrangieren es geht nun um seine
totale Unschädlichmachung Vernichtung
und Auslöschung damit stellen sie sich
jedoch einer viel ehrgeizigeren
Herausforderung sie müssen nicht nur die
chamas militärisch auslöschen nein Sie
müssen hier zuu den Gasastreifen für
immer verändern und zwar vollkommen und
was ist das Problem dabei nun es ist
leider etwas dass sie mit Gewalt tun
müssen aber Gewalt wird nicht ausreichen
wir reden hier nicht von einer einfachen
Operation der Kampf in städtischen
Gebieten ist die schwierigste Art der
Kriegsführung so die israelischen
Streitkräfte 2014 die Operation
protective Edge durch eine Operation die
darauf abzielte die militärischen
Fähigkeiten der Hamas zu reduzieren ja
das war ein viel begrenzteres Ziel als
das was jetzt verfolgt wird und
Intervention war auch viel kleiner in
ihrem Umfang sie drangen erst gar nicht
in die Herzen der Städte ein trotzdem
dauerte die landinvasion 19 Tage und die
gesamte Operation 7 Wochen die IDF
hatten dabei 67 Opfer zu beklagen und
angesichts der aktuellen Ziele könnte
das Resultat viel viel gravierender
ausfallen
wie ihr alle wisst ist den Israelis im
Gegensatz zu Hamas jedes einzelne
Menschenleben heilig genau aus diesem
Grund haben die israelischen
Streitkräfte bevor sie sich in ein
Stahlgewitter stürzen taktische Ziele
ins Visier genommen und tausende von
Bomben auf alle möglichen Gebäude und
Einrichtungen abgeworfen wie gesagt
nicht ohne zuvor die Zivilbevölkerung zu
warnen und nicht nur das im Prinzip ist
die israelische Armee eine der am besten
für den stadtkampf ausgebildeten Armeen
der Welt wenn nicht sogar die beste das
ist logischerweise kein zu Fall sonder
liegt daran dass ihre Truppen regelmäßig
an antiterroroperationen im
Westjordanland teilnehmen und auch daran
dass die Israelis 2005 sogar eine Stadt
namens baladia als militärischen
Übungsplatz gebaut haben baladia ist die
Nachbildung einer typischen nahöstlichen
Stadtstruktur eine Stadt mit engen
Gassen Moscheen Wohnhochhäusern und
allen möglichen Tricks und fallen eine
Stadt in der übrigens auch ein großer
Teil der Serie fauder gedreht
wurde aber natürlich geht die Infanterie
nicht allein herein israel hat nicht nur
10 000 von Männern für die gazaoperation
mobilisiert sondern auch eine enorme
Menge an Artillerie Panzern gepanzerten
mannschafttransportern drohen
ferngesteuerten Geräten riesigen
bulldoern und Spezialisten aller Art
zusammengetragen trotz alldem ist der
Einmarsch in Gaza wahrscheinlich eine
der schwierigsten Mission die die
israelische Armee je unternommen hat die
Frage die sich viele von euch daher
sicher stellen lautet also warum
eigentlich sollte die enorme
militärische Überlegenheit der
legendären israelischen Armee die einst
gegen übermächtige riffe ihrer
Nachbarstaaten triumphierte nicht
ausreichen um eine Terrortruppe wie der
Hamas den G auszum machen nun nein nicht
unbedingt die Dinge sind ein bisschen
komplizierter und asymmetrischer ein
urbaner Kampf in einem Gebiet mit so
viel Bebauung wie Gaza City ist nicht
einfach angefangen bei der Tatsache dass
die Hamas und ihre rund 30 000 Kämpfer
sich seit einiger Zeit auf diesen Moment
vorbereitet haben die Heras wartet die
Heras hat sich auf die Boden asion
vorbereitet und es wird Tote geben daran
besteht kein Zweifel stadtkämpfe sind
sehr langsam langwierig und kostspielig
es gibt keinen einfachen Weg mit ihnen
umzugehen wenn du es mit einem Gegner zu
tun hast der urbanes terrin verteidigt
vor allem wenn er Zeit hatte eine gute
Verteidigung vorzubereiten und der nicht
so schnell aufgeben wird dann braucht es
Zeit aber das ist noch nicht alles neben
der Vorbereitung können wir fünf weitere
Faktoren benennen warum diese Operation
in Gaza extrem kompliziert sein
könnte
erstens die Raketen die Kamas hat
tausende und abertausende von Raketen
einige Zahlen deuten darauf hin dass ihr
verbleibender Bestand an Raketen
wahrscheinlich über 5000 Stück beträgt
Raketen mit denen diese Gruppe
israelische Bodentruppen angreifen
könnte die versuchen in den
gaserstreifen einzudringen zweitens ist
die Nutzung von Höhen im stadtkampf für
die angreifenden Truppen besonders
problematisch scharfschüssen können sich
verstecken und vorrügende Truppen
angreifen während Gebäude den Schall
verdecken und verzerren Panzer und
andere gepanzerte Fahrzeuge sind
ebenfalls anfällig für diese Angriffe
durch ihr hohes Profil sind sie leicht
zu entdecken und anzugreifen während
sich die angriffer leichter verstecken
können im stadtkrieg kann es Tage dauern
bis ein einzelnes Gebäude fällt und
gesäubert wird vor allem wenn es sich um
Beton und Stahlkonstruktionen handelt
und wisst ihr was ich denke ein Bild von
gazastadt wie das das ihr gerade auf dem
Bildschirm seht macht uns das
potentielle Labyrinth von dem wir
sprechen sehr deutlich und denk bitte
daran selbst wenn man diese Gebäude
zerstört schafft der Schutt selbst Räume
die den Vormarsch verlangsamen und den
Verteidigern gar ganz neue füron den
Angreifern nicht vorhersehbare
Möglichkeiten bieten sich in sicheren
Stellungen zu verschanzen und aus dies
dann anzugreifen Hinterhalte zu bilden
und so
[Musik]
weiter und drittens wären da noch die
Zivilisten sie erschweren alle
Kampfeinsätze erheblich die Anwesenheit
von Zivilisten kann die Kampfkraft die
in einem Gebiet eingesetzt werden kann
einschränken sie erhöhen den
internationalen Druck und machen es viel
schwieriger die Verteidiger ausfindig zu
machen im Grunde haben es die
Verteidiger dadurch leichter unbemerkt
zu bleiben und Hilfe oder Nachschub zu
erhalten in einem dicht besiedelten
Gebiet wie gazastff ist es für die
israelischen streitkriftter nlich sehr
schwierig Aktionen mit sehr offensiven
Charakter durchzuführen erinnert ihr
euch noch an die berühmte Evakuierung
des nördlichen Teils des Streifens zu
der die Israels die gasaner wiederholt
und mit Nachdruck aufgefordert haben und
die die Hamas vehement zu verhindern
versuchte nun das ist genau der Punkt
die massenevakuierungen zu denen Israel
aufgefordert hat Zielen nicht nur darauf
ab die Zahl der zivilen Opfer zu
verringern sondern auch und
wahrscheinlich vor allem darauf die
Verzerrung der Kampfzonen zu Gunsten der
Verteidiger durch die Anwesenheit von
Zivilisten zu minimieren und denkt daran
dass dies keine klein it ist das Problem
ist nämlich dass die hamasterroristen
echte Spezialisten für den Einsatz von
menschlichen Schutzschilden sind
zweifelt bitte kein Moment daran dass
sie diese Fähigkeit bis zum Anschlag
ausnutzen werden der Chef der Hamas
selbst hat kürzlich Vergleiche mit dem
Kampf der Sowjets gegen die Nazis
gezogen und gemeint jedes Volk müsse
eben Millionen Menschen leben für seine
Freiheit opfern was er meinte war
natürlich sein eigenes Bankkonto denn
natürlich sagt sich sowas sehr leicht
wenn man derwil ein sicheres Leben in
Luxushotels im Ausland führen und sich
die Taschen mit der internationalen
Hilfe für Gaza vollstopfen kann aber das
ist ein Thema für ein anderes Video der
vierte Faktor der die israelische
Invasion erschweren könnte hat viel mit
Waffen und Informationen zu tun es ist
bekannt dass diese arabische
Terrorgruppe in den letzten Jahren
zahlreiche drohen aus dem Iran bekommen
hat ebenso wie panzerabwehrsysteme und
leistungsstarke straßenrandbomben eine
Ausrüstung die vor allem in städtischen
Gebieten tödlich ist weil es so
schwierig ist sie zu orten und so
neutralisieren im Bewusstsein der
enormen Gefahr die von diesem Waffentyp
ausgeht und erst recht nach den
desaströsen Erfahrungen der Russen in
der Ukraine setzt Israel jetzt auf
seinen neuen nAmer 1500 eines der am
besten gepanzerten und geschützten
infanterietransportfahrzeuge der Welt es
basiert auf dem Merkava 4 Panzer und
wiegt 65 Ton es handelt sich um ein
Ungetüm das sogar über ein
Raketenabwehrsystem verfügt das eine Art
Schutzschild um das Fahrzeug bildet
alles einschließlich der
Maschinengewehre wird vom Inneren des
Fahrzeugs ausgesteuert die Idee dahinter
ist dass es Soldaten in absoluter
Sicherheit transportieren kann und wir
werden nun sehen wie effektiv es sich in
der harten Praxis tatsächlich schlägt
auf jeden Fall sind zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt noch nicht so viele Einheiten
verfügbar und andere infanteriefahrzeuge
haben sich als viel anfälliger für
tragbare panzerabwehrsysteme erwiesen
dies wird also einer der großen
Herausforderung der gesamten
bodenoperation
darstellt und ihr könnt Gift darauf
nehmen dass die Hamas und ihre
iranischen Ausbilder die
Verteidigungsstrategie der Ukrainer
gegen die Russen minuziö studiert und
die dabei erzielten Revolution
Erkenntnisse für die asymmetrische
Kriegsführung gegen einen quantitativ
überleeggenen Gegner zur Anwendung
bringen wollen und täuscht euch nicht
das Spektrum der technischen und
taktischen Mittel der Allianz Iran Gaza
sind durchaus mit den der Allianz USA
Ukraine vergleichbar wenn auch auf
entsprechend kleineren Maßstab ihr
glaubt mir nicht dann passt mal gut auf
die iranischen Revolutionsgarden haben
am 27 September ihren Satelliten nur 3
auf einer kassamrakete erfolgreich in
die Erdumlaufbahn gebracht diese ist mit
mit hochpräzisionskameras ausgestattet
die eine erhebliche Verbesserung
gegenüber seinen Vorgängern darstellen
diese Ausrüstung macht es dem Iran
leichter das Geschehen vor Ort zu
überwachen und diese Information dann
mit der Hamas zu teilen es handelt sich
um ein von den meisten Beobachtern
strälich vernachlässigtes Detail das
jedoch ohnglaublich kriegsentscheiden
sein kann sollte es den Iranern gelingen
ihre Kommunikation mit der Hamas
aufrecht zu erhalten wäre einer der
größten Vorteile Israels dahin der
Informationsvorsprung in diesem Licht
ist auch die gefährliche Ankündigung
Elon Musk zu werten sein Sitten
internetsystem starlink im Gasastreifen
zur Verfügung zu stellen er sagte zwar
er wolle es nur Hilfsorganisation zur
Verfügung stellen aber wie ich bald in
einem Video auf meinem persönlichen
Kanal ausführen werde sind zahlreiche
davon schon seit Jahren von der Hamas
und ihren Sympathisanten unterwandert
viele ihrer dortigen Agenten warten also
nur darauf der Hamas Zugang zu masks
moderner Kommunikationsinfrastruktur zu
ermöglichen es ist zum Teil wirklich
erschreckend wie viel Genialität und
zugleich Naivität sich in diesem Mann
vereinigen aber auch das ist ein anderes
Thema denn meine Lieben Zuschauer wenn
wir über die Hamas den Gazastreifen und
eine Invasion sprechen müssen wir uns
auch über das wichtigste Element
überhaupt unterhalten dass die Hamas
Kräfte haben die Rede ist von nichts
anderem als von den berüchtigten
terrortunneln die den Untergrund gasas
durchziehen und ich kann jetzt schon
sagen dass ich glaube dass ihr ziemlich
überrascht sein werdet was ich nun über
sie erzählen werde also passt jetzt
bitte noch mal besonders gut
auf Gaza
U-Bahn wenn wir von den terrortunneln in
Gazas Untergrund sprechen meinen wir
keine kleinen Höhlengänge oder
Schlupfwinkel sondern eine riesiges
Netzwerk von Tunneln Kommandozentralen
rüstungsanlagen Lagern Lazaretten ja
ganzen unterirdischen Städten und
Waffenfabriken einer gewaltigen
subterranen Festungs und
militärinfrastruktur um euch eine
Vorstellung davon zu geben der
politische Führer der Hamas in Gaza
Yahya sinware behaup tete im Jahr 2021
dass seine Terrororganisation über mehr
als 500 km Tunnel im gesamten
Gazastreifen verfüge ganz genau ihr hab
richtig gehört mehr als 500 km an
Tunneln viel mehr als die gesamte Länge
der Londoner U-Bahn und sogar mehr als
die Tunnel der Viet Kong während des
Vietnamkriegs im Vergleich zu damals
handelt es sich dabei aber auch um
wesentlich ausgeklügeltere und tiefere
Tunnel die in der Regel über eine eigene
Beleuchtung Stromerzeugung Belüftung und
Kommunikationsnetze verfügen die
israelischen Truppen nennen sie
umgangssprach als die Gaza Metro also
die Gaza U-Bahn denn um Luftangriffen
Stand zuuh halten sind viele der neueren
Tunnel bis zu 40 m tief gebaut verfügen
über Schienensysteme und sind selbst mit
Lastwagen befahrbar Schätzung zufolge
waren für ihren Bau über 60.000 Tonn
Beton notwendig und der Hammer ist dass
die Hamas diese Infrastruktur seit mehr
als 10 Jahren vorbereiten konnte und ja
wie einige von euch wahrscheinlich
vermuten wurde sie zu einem großen Teil
mit dem Zement dem Baumaterial den
Maschinen und der bauausrüstung gebaut
die verschiedene Regierungen und NGOs im
Laufe der Jahre nach Gaza geschickt
haben um angeblich Hilfsprojekte für die
Zivilbevölkerung zu fördern erinnert ihr
euch noch was ich euch in einem früheren
Video über die von der EU gelieferten
Wasserrohre erzählt habe die die Hamas
zu Raketen umfunktioniert nun hierbei
handelt es sich um eine sehr ähnliche
Geschichte und lasst euch nicht von
heuchlerischen Politikern im Westen mit
Sprüchen an der Nase herumführen die
Gelder und materiellen Hilfen in
Milliardenhöhe die Sie ins von der
Hammers kontrollierte Gasa schicken
würden nicht zu terrorzwecken
missbraucht werden dabei erwiderte der
precher Abu marsuk auch noch in einem
Fernsehinterview die Frage wieso die
chamas zwar 500 km Tunnel jedoch keine
Luftschutzbunker für die
Zivilbevölkerung errichtet hätte nur mit
der zynischen Antwort die Tunnel seinen
ja den mitglieden der Hamas vorbehalten
für die Bürger Gazas seien doch die
Vereinten Nationen verantwortlich es
wäre einfach nur lachhaft wenn es nicht
so traurig wäre also denkt doch einfach
jedes Mal wenn euch irgendein Politiker
den Bären aufbindet eure Steuergelder
würden nicht in Waffen Infrastruktur und
andere Mittel für Terroristen fließen an
eines die Hamas prallte sogar in einem
eigenen Musikvideo 2021 damit wie sie
die Wasserrohre aus der EU zu Raketen
umschweißt und jeder dieser Politiker
weiß ganz genau dass die Hamas ohne ihre
Hilfe niemals in der Lage gewesen wäre
ein derart aufwendiges Terrornetzwerk
inklusive technische Ausstattung und
topbewaffnung zu errichten der Kampf in
der Stadt ist extrem schwierig es geht
nur langsam voran und im Fall des
gasastreifens wird es sogar noch
schwieriger weil die Heras im Laufe der
Zeit ein tunnelness gebaut hat und weil
sie viel Zeit hat sich auf diesen Kampf
vorzubereiten wir sprechen hier nicht
über ein lebensichtchliches
Detail diese Tunnel sind von wahrlich
kriegsentscheidender Bedeutung denn alle
Operationen der Hamas werden über diese
Routen abgewickelt in ihnen befinden
sich Montagelinien für Raketen Motoren
und Waffen munitions und nchschublager
Kommandoposten und die Wohnräume vieler
hamaskämpfer und Führer und natürlich
werden sie auch für den Schmuggel von
Ausrüstung und Nachschub aus Ägypten
genutzt das Tunnelsystem ermöglichicht
den jihadistischen Terroristen auch sich
vor der israelischen Offensive zu
schützen unentdeckt zu manövrieren und
Angriffe aus dem Hinterhalt zu starten
außerdem verlaufen viele von ihnen unter
großen Gebäuden sowie Schulen
Krankenhäusern und Moscheen um es Israel
schwerer zu machen sich zu
neutralisieren und im Idealfall unschöne
Bilder kollateral getroffener Zivilisten
zu produzieren und bedenkt bitte dass
Tunnel auch leichter zu verteidigen
sind der durchschnittliche chamastunnel
misst etwa 2 m in der Höhe und 1 m in
der Breite was bedeutet das eine kleine
Truppe ein Zugang gegen eine viel
größere Zahl von Soldaten verteidigen
kann hinzu kommt dass Soldaten die diese
Tunnel eindringen möglicherweise
Schwierigkeiten haben mit der Außenwelt
zu
kommunizieren Israel versucht diese
Vorteile der Hamas mit Mitteln wie z.B
Robotern oder sogenannten spongebombs zu
kontern das sind Bomben bei deren
Explosion sich im Tunnel ein Schaum
ausdehnt und sie somit unpassierbar
macht aber trotz alldem bilden diese
Tunnel den wahrscheinlich größten
strategischen Vorteil der chamas und den
schlimmsten Albtraum für die
israelischen Truppen Jihadisten bewegen
sich durch sie hindurch springen
unerwartet aus ihnen heraus grereifen
aus den Hinterhalten an und ziehen sich
dann in ein meist unbekanntes und schier
endloses Netzwerk zurück sie sind der
Art wichtig dass Israel spezielle
Einheiten gebildet hat die nach ihnen
suchen und in ihnen operieren z.B die
jahalominheit ein Elitekommando das auf
das Aufspüren säubern und Zerstören von
Tunneln spezialisiert ist sie haben auch
eine Menge spezieller Ausrüstung und
Sprengstoff entwickelt die für diese Art
von Operationen geeignet sind ich werde
Kürze auf meinem persönlichen Kanal ein
Video veröffentlichen das auf einem
Interview basiert welches ich mit einem
auf dem tunnelkampf spezialisierten
idfofizier geführt habe und indem er mir
auch viele eurer Fragen aus den
Kommentaren und den Livestreams
beantwortet hat also vergesst bitte
nicht dort vorbeizuschauen und auch
meinen neuen Kanal zu abonnieren falls
ihr das noch nicht getan habt ich
verlinke ihn euch jetzt hinter dem i
oben rechts und unter dem Video eine
wichtige Botschaft die ich aus meinem
Gespräch mit dem idfszialisten mitnehmen
konnte waren sicherlich die historischen
Erfahrungen und Präzedenzfälle die uns
lehren das Israel nicht aufgibt und dass
es trotz des extremen Hindernisses die
die hamastunel darstellen am Ende die
ganze Stadt ob über oder unter der Erde
kontrollieren wird aber Moment mal über
welche Erfahrungen und präzidenzfälle
rede ich hier nun ich habe Euch doch
versprochen dass dieses Video
unkonventionell wird und deswegen werden
wir unseren Blick in die Geschichte
diesmal ganz zum Schluss in selbige
werfen denn nur mit diesem
geschichtlichen und kontextualen
Verständnis können wir uns ein wirklich
vollständiges Bild von Entwicklung und
dem Ausgang bilden
aufgepasst wird Gas
abfallen meine Lieben Zuschauer die
Wahrheit ist dass wir in dieser ganzen
Angelegenheit der urbanen Kriegsführung
ziemlich aktuelle Präzedenzfälle finden
können und einige sind der Situation in
Gaza sogar sehr ähnlich wenn Israel tut
was es sagt nämlich die zu stürzen und
ihre militärischen iten zu zerstören
haben wir es mit einem Mosul im gesamten
Gazastreifen zu tun der Feldzug gegen
den islamischen Staat in Mosul im Jahr
2017 weist viele Parallelen auf
angefangen bei der Tatsache dass die
Bevölkerung mossuls ähnlich groß war wie
die von Gaza und auch weil Isis 2 Jahre
lang Tunnel gegraben hat der Feldzug
gegen den terrorstat erforderte den
Einsatz von mehr als 100.000 irakischen
Soldaten die von usstitkräften
unterstützt worden er erstreckte sich
über neun lange Monate wie ihr euch
vorstellen könnt war es Überraschung
dass der größte Teil der Stadt danach in
trömern lag in der Tat grauenhaft ein
weiteres noch aktuelleres Beispiel war
die russische Belagerung Mario POS im
Jahr
2022 eine Schlacht die trotz der
damaligen russischen Dominanz zu Lande
zu Wasser und in der Luft Putins
Streitkräften schwere Verluste zugefügt
hat und fast drei Monate dauerte die
Bilder die wir alle gesehen haben Inel
denen von Mossul sehr stark überall nur
Zerstörung in beiden Fällen waren die
offensiven erfolgreich aber sie hatten
einen sehr hohen
Preis natürlich ist das israelische
Militär viel besser ausgebildet
kompetenter fähiger und erfahrener als
die russischen oder irakischen
Streitkräfte daran besteht kein Zweifel
aufbauend auf den historischen
Erfahrungen wird Israel jedoch versuchen
bewrte Konzepte zu übernehmen
gleichzeitig jedoch auch aus den dort
begangenen Fehlern lehren sie die IDF
scheinen dabei den Ratschlägen ihres
Verbündeten den USA zu folgen laut
US-Medien hat die beiden Regierung
Israel dazu gedrängt auf eine
großangelegte Bodenoffensive zu
verzichten und stattdessen chirurgische
Operationen durchzuführen
interessanterweise ist dies also genau
der entgegengesetzte Ratschlag den
Stimmen aus dem Pentagon im Sommer der
Ukraine erteilen wollten könnte es sein
dass man in Washington bzw Arlington von
den Ukrainern doch etwas gelernt hat tja
wer weiß auf jeden Fall würde diese
Strategie dazu beitragen zivile Opfer
und eine Eskalation in der Region zu
vermeiden durch den Verzicht auf eine
wirklich große und umfassende
Bodenoffensive könnte sich auch die vom
Iran finanzierte Terrorgruppe hisbalah
die mörden operiert zurückhalten da sie
immer gewarnt hat sich im Falle eines
großen Krieges einzumischen aber darüber
haben wir bereits im letzten Video
gesprochen Naftali Benett der ehemalige
Ministerpräsident Israels hebt hervor
dass kleinere Angriffe in der Regel
weniger zivile Opfer verursachen was der
Hamas natürlich nicht gefallen würde da
sie erwartet dass Israel erhebliche
Kollateralschäden verursacht die die
theoristen dann medial und
propagandistisch ausschlachten können
und Benett betont dass Israel auf keinen
Fall so agieren sollte wie die Hamas es
erwart er hat ein zehn Punkteplan
erstellt um eine regional Eskalation zu
vermeiden durch kleinere Operation
könnten die israelischen Verluste
minimiert werden und solche Angriffe
wären dann auch kein Grund für die
hisbalah und den Iran direkt in den
Konflikt einzugreifen und es wäre für
Israel durchaus klug zuerst die Hamas zu
eliminieren und sich dann erst später
der hisbalah und dem Iran zu widmen
Benet schlägt auch vor die Hamas im
Norden Gazas vollständig zu isolieren
und sie in den Tunneln auszutrocknen bis
sie gezwungen sind diese zu verlassen
die Bewohner des gasastreifens sollten
bis zum Kriegsende in der der südlichen
Hälfte oder außerhalb bleiben die
israelische Strategie im Umgang mit der
Hamas scheint aufgrund der jüngsten
militärischen Operation also eine Abkehr
von einer groß angelegten Bodenoffensive
darzustellen stattdessen haben die IDF
offenbar einen unkonventionellen Ansatz
gewählt der von manchen Analysten als
israelische gerilla Taktik bezeichnet
wird dieser Ansatz beinhaltet gezielte
Angriffe und den regelmäßigen Wechsel
der Orte an denen diese Angriffe
stattfinden um die Hamas in Schach zu
halten durch ein ständiges Verwirrspiel
könnte die IDF im entscheinenden Moment
zuschlagen wenn die Hamas ihre wach
amkeit verliert denn wie sollte man
Asymmetrie besser Kontern als mit noch
mehr Asymmetrie so könnten die
israelischen Einheiten aus verschiedenen
Richtungen angreifen und durch diese
multiplen Operationen und begrenzten
Aktionen mit intensiver Feuerkraft und
Luftunterstützung die die Hamas nicht
genau vorhersehen kann ihre Kampfkraft
und Logistik auszähen ganz ähnlich wie
es die Ukraine mit den Russen machen auf
diese Weise würde sich der Kreis
schließen nachdem die Hamas sich etwas
von der Kriegskunst der Ukraine
abgeschaut hat z.B den drohenkrieg um
Israel zu übertölpeln werden die
Israelis nun beweisen wollen dass Sie am
Ende die agileren und besseren Lehrlinge
die Musterschüler kievs sein werden aber
was meint ihr wer wird diesen
adaptionswettbewerb an eine moderne und
zeitgemäße Kriegsführung wohl gewinnen
nun wie wir alle wissen spiegelt jede
Truppe nur die Gesellschaft wieder aus
der sie entspringt und natürlich deren
Mentalitäten und Qualitäten wie z.B
Lernfähigkeit mentale Beweglichkeit
sozialen Zusammenhalt und moralisch
ethische Geisteshaltung und ich würde
mal behaupten dass dabei die Israelis
einfach den längeren Atem haben werden
aber wir sprechen trotzdem natürlich
immer noch von einer extrem schwierigen
und riskanten Operation denn selbst wenn
Israel am Ende den Sieg davon trägt
besteht ein hohes Risiko dass es sich um
einen pyrosieg handeln könnte der dem
hebräerstaat am Ende vielleicht sogar
das Genick brechen könnte einige
Analysten sprechen gar von einer Falle
die der Iran den Israelis gestellt hat
und dabei die Opferung seines arabischen
Proxis der für die Mulas entbehrlichen
sunitischen hammas mitsamt der
Bevölkerung Gazas gerne Kauf nimmt es
ist eine ausgemachte Sache die chas wird
in Gaza taktisch besiegt werden sie kann
Gaza nicht nachhaltig verteidigen
militärisch ist der gaserastreifen wie
eine Insel es gibt keine wirksame
Verteidigung des gaserastreifens weil
die hers keine Möglichkeit hat sich mit
Nachschub zu versorgen und über keinen
rückwärtigen Raum verfügt um die
Operation an der Front zu unterstützen
das größte Problem stellt ohnehin die
Tatsache da dass die Bevölkerung Gazas
nicht so einfach von der Hamas zu
trennen ist es geht nicht nur um 30.000
direkte militante Hamas Mitglieder
sondern auch um Hunderttausende ihrer
Bewunderer und Unterstützer knallharte
Fanatiker die von klein auf einer
radikalen Gehirnwäsche ausgesetzt waren
und zwar in Schulen die von der EU und
un finanziert wurden sie sind vollkommen
darauf getrimmt Israel bis aufs Blut zu
hassen und für die Auslöschung des
jüdischen Volkes nicht nur ihr eigenes
sondern auch das Leben ihrer Kinder und
Kindeskinder zu opfern es wird erwartet
dass insgesamt 1,4 Millionen gasaner aus
ihren Häusern im Norden in den süen
ziehen müssen während die gesamte
Bevölkerung des Gazastreifens natürlich
unter schweren engpessssen Leiden wird
Israel hat seine freiwilligen Strom
Treibstoff und lebensmittellieferung
nach Gaza so lange unterbrochen bis die
Hamas die Gefangenen Geisel ausliefert
das alles ist den Hamas Führern die ein
luxuriöses Leben in Qatar fühlen
natürlich nicht nur egal es kommt ihnen
gerade recht denn es ist Wasser auf den
möhlen jenes opferkuls auf denen ihr
Geschäftsmodell beruht die große
Zukunftsfrage ist daher wie Israel nach
einem militärischen Sieg die noch viel
größere Herausforderung wird lösen
wollen nämlich die schier un schöpflich
wirkende Quelle an terrornachwuchs aus
der Gaza Zivilbevölkerung in Kombination
mit ihrer nicht abreien wollenden
milliardenschweren Finanzierung aus dem
Ausland den Iran Qatar aber auch aus dem
Westen all das werden wir den kommenden
Videos hier auf visualpitik auf visual
conomic und auf meinem neuen Kanal
ausfühlich analysieren und euch wie
immer prägnante und zielführende
Antworten liefern wenn ihr also einen
unserer Kanäle noch nicht abonniert habt
zögert bitte nicht es ist zu 100%
kostenlos und mit dem Glöckchen könnt
ihr auch aktiv bestimmen was ihr
wirklich sehen wollt und zwar ohne dass
euer severhalten durch einen
intransparenten anonymen Algorithmus
gesteuert wird tja und jetzt würde mich
natürlich noch eure Meinung zu diesem
brisanten Thema interessieren glaubt ihr
dass die israelische Bodenoffensive
reibungslos verlaufen oder für die IDF
eher verlustreich sein wird wird die
israelische Regierung ihre
selbstgesteckten Ziele erreichen können
wird es ihr gelingen die Hamas zu
vernichten und wie könnte es gelingen
eine endgültige Lösung für diesen
Konflikt zu finden schreibt uns eure
Einschätzungen bitte in den
Kommentarbereich unter diesem Video denn
wie immer sind wir auf eure Diskussion
und eure Anregung zu diesem Thema schon
mächtig gespannt ich hoffe dass euch
dies Video gefallen hat und ihr
vielleicht auch etwas dabei gelernt habt
falls ja gebt uns ein Like Fall mit
euren Freunden und diskutiert es auch
mit ihnen natürlich freuen wir uns auch
jederzeit über eine Spende von euch mit
un dieses Projekt weiterzuführen den
Link dazu findet ihr in der Beschreibung
oder dem Video macht's gut und bis
[Musik]
bald